this week
on brian ross investigates made in
america
walmart and other big retailers tout
their commitment to selling
made in america products and now
president biden like his predecessor
underscores the message and the key
plank of ensuring the future will be
made in america but walmart is now being
accused of deceiving consumers
about what is actually made in america
many of walmart's
own products its own brand products
that were marketed as made in usa
completely imported made in china
it's the same allegation made against
walmart almost three decades ago
involving clothing made and a notorious
asian sweatshop
from what we saw in bangladesh it would
be hard to overlook the fact that
lots of children young children were
making clothes for walmart
will president biden's administration
enforce the law
about what can be labeled made in
america
plus enemies foreign and domestic what
to do about the revelation of so many
members of the military
and police forces involved in the riot
and insurrection
at the capitol we'll be joined by
counter-terrorism expert
richard clark and this week's winners
and losers in the media
see if you agree with the editors of
mediaite on their choices for
who got it right who got it wrong
[Music]
from the lawn crime trial network this
is bryan ross investigate
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live
i'm brian ross joined by my colleague
rhonda schwartz at law and crime
and rhonda we begin with made in america
or
is it president biden this week
announced steps his administration will
take to push for
made in america products just like
president trump did during his term in
office
but tonight there are questions about
what that phrase made in america
really means and whether american
consumers are being deceived about it by
some very big retailers rhonda
that's right it's a great sales tactic
and
consumers love it but consumer advocate
groups say the rules are
fuzzy and not often enforced there is no
requirement no pre-approval is required
to put a made in the usa label or an
american flag on your products
and the rules allow even small parts to
be
included that are made overseas even in
the trust territories as far away as
guam
brian it's uh something that consumer
groups are really looking into
absolutely it's one thing to say made in
america it's quite another to actually
do it
and for the biden administration to
actually enforce it
this is our moment to build a new
american economy when we spend taxpayers
money we should use it to buy
american products and support american
jobs
and the key plank of ensuring the future
will be
made in america even before the
president's announcement this week
some of america's biggest companies had
already jumped on the made in america
bandwagon
this walmart ad boasts of a 250
billion dollar commitment to made in
america products
but over the years walmart has been
caught again and again
using the made in america labels for
products that were not made in america
the federal trade commission five years
ago reported that walmart
had removed made in america logos from
its website
and now a prominent consumer advocacy
group is alleging
walmart's deception continues we're
joined now by bonnie
patton who's the executive director of a
non-profit consumer advocacy group
called
truth and advertising tina.org ms patton
thank you so much for joining us
how did you begin to investigate what
was going on with walmart
well we actually received a consumer tip
in 2015 that walmart was deceptively
advertising made in the u.s products and
that's what really got us started
and what did you discover what we
discovered
was hundreds of products being sold
at uh walmart.com the online shop
uh as made in the usa that did not meet
the ftc's legal definition
of made in the usa and what sort of
products did you discover among the
dozens you found
well originally when we investigated
them in 2015 we found
many of walmart's own products its own
brand
products uh that were marketed as made
in the usa
completely imported made in china uh for
example
they had equate uh makeup
sponges uh marketed made in the usa
when they were really made in china um
but
we found items from clothing
to um supplements
anything you could think of we found an
example where they
uh were marketed as made in the usa when
they
did not meet that legal definition
when our executive producer rhonda
schwartz and i worked at nbc news in
1992
we found the same thing that walmart was
selling products
as if they were made in the usa in fact
they were not made often times by
child labor in bangladesh and other
third world countries
to the 12 year old be in school or
making clothes for walmart
anywhere in the world no we a
twelve-year-old girl should not
but they are we saw them well we have
not been able to substantiate that
but from what we saw in bangladesh it
would be hard to overlook the fact that
lots of children
young children were making clothes for
walmart
well i think this is one of the issues
they've been getting away with this for
obviously multiple years and you know
made in the usa marketing pays so
walmart
knows that american consumers want to
buy products
that are listed as made in the usa
absolutely american consumers want to
buy
products that are made in the usa for a
variety of reasons from patriotism to
supporting our economy
jobs here in america to a belief that
the quality of made in the usa products
is better than that of foreign
competitive products now your group has
investigated companies in addition to
walmart what else have you been finding
out there
well we found that a lot of very
established
uh sophisticated corporations have been
lying to consumers about
made into the u.s origin claims from
gillette and at our factory in boston
1200 workers are starting their day
putting money back in the pockets of
millions of americans
to william sonoma um
pottery barn knowing you know the
associates that we have
the jobs that we create and you know the
income that they can provide for their
families
is is the most important thing for me
all of them have made deceptive claims
to american consumers about made in the
usa
origin claims with pottery barn some
products made for children right
absolutely things like
uh baby mattresses that are
marketed as made in the usa when they're
actually imported
and what is the legal definition
according to the federal trade
commission
if you assemble products that are made
overseas but you assemble them here in
the u.s
is that not made in the usa
well that would be considered a
qualified claim so what you need to tell
consumers is
you know yes it's assembled here but
with
imported parts and components so
the key for the law is that you have to
clearly and conspicuously
give consumers the information that they
really desire
so you can't make the unqualified claim
made in the us
but you could make the qualified claim
made in the us
with uh imported parts
what kind of reaction do you get from
these companies when you knock on their
doors and say what you've discovered
as a general matter they try and clean
up the mass
as quickly as possible with regard to
walmart
they've come up with a lot of excuses
over the years
saying it was coding errors blaming
other companies that advertise on their
online website
but never really taking full
responsibility for the deceptive
marketing and what about response from
the federal trade commission the ftc the
government agency that oversees this
issue
well recently they've become very
aggressive
in going after companies that uh falsely
claim
products are made in the usa when we
brought the william sonoma
uh information to their attention
it was the second time that uh william
sonoma had been to the ftc
and they were fined a million dollars
what do you think would make companies
stop
doing this deceptive advertising well i
think that the ftc needs to get much
more aggressive
in uh their enforcement of such claims
when they when they discover them i
think the only way that
companies will stop doing this is if it
is more expensive to deceive consumers
than not so if any of our viewers have
questions or tips how do they get them
to you
simply go to tina.org and you'll find
form there that you could
uh fill out and let us know we're also
on social media platforms and you can
let us know
there too bonnie patton executive
director of truth and advertising
tina.org
thank you so much for joining us this
evening thank you it's been my pleasure
we asked walmart to comment on our
report tonight but they declined and
declined to have anyone appear on the
program
ed williams and sonoma by the way
settled last year for one million
dollars to answer complaints
they had misled consumers about made in
the usa
coming up enemies foreign and domestic
what to do about both
we're joined by the former
counterterrorism and cyber czar
richard clark you're watching brian ross
investigates on the law and crime
trial network
american officials take an oath of
office they swear to defend
the united states constitution against
all entities foreign and domestic
and in the last month we've seen we have
plenty of both kinds
to talk about this we're joined now by
richard clark the former white house
counterterrorism
and cyber czar author of the most recent
book warnings
mr clark thanks for being here you also
wrote something called
against all enemies were you surprised
to see so many domestic enemies against
which
we must defend i wasn't surprised brian
but the problem is
all of the billions of dollars we have
invested in counter-terrorism since 9 11
has all focused on foreign enemies it's
not
really useful most of it for dealing
with this new threat that we have
and the government has been very
reluctant in the past
to investigate our domestic terrorist
threat
even though most terrorist crimes in the
united states
for the last decade have been by
domestic terrorists
we see the photos of a retired u.s air
force colonel on the floor of the united
states senate
addressed in paramilitary gear and with
reports that one out of five of the
people in that insurrection
had ties to either the military or to
law enforcement
well that's right we don't exactly know
what the numbers are nationwide
but it's a problem it's a serious
problem and
only now our law enforcement agencies
around the country
uh being asked to do some background
checking and see
uh if any of their people were involved
in the capital incident
but how do you do that how do you do
that checking if you can't
look at their phone calls if you can't
look at their emails
it's very hard to know if you don't have
the authority illegally to look at their
facebook pages or their twitter accounts
we have laws in this country for very
good reason
to protect our privacy rights uh and our
civil liberties
and those laws make it difficult uh with
good reason
uh to investigate people in the united
states uh
if they are domestic terrorists uh
i know no one wants to infringe on civil
liberties and certainly i don't
but we have to find some way of
balancing uh
our constitutional guaranteed liberties
with our need for security
against enemies among us
exactly mr clark a question for you from
rhonda schwartz rhonda
and while all this is going on we still
have some of our traditional enemies
overseas
for example how serious was this recent
hack
from russia well rendez was incredibly
serious it was the largest hack in
history
and it put back doors that allow the
russians to get back
in into hundreds of american companies
and government agencies so there are two
things going on right now
one the government is working very very
hard to see if it can
find these back doors in the government
networks
and see if it can get the russians out
of our networks
that will be a difficult task based on
past experience
and the other thing that's going on is
the president has asked
his national security council
to engage with the intelligence
community on the study
of what the russians have done over the
course of the last four years
not just in cyber but also in poisoning
their their
internal enemies and a whole host of
things that they have done including
undermining the american election
process the biden administration is
apparently
before they retaliate for
this hack they want to know what they
should what else
should they retaliate for and how does
this hack
fit into an overall pattern with russia
and let me ask you this do you think the
us needs to retaliate in a like manner
than the hack of our own against russia
i don't necessarily think we need to do
like for like
uh but i do think we need to retaliate i
would preferably
do the retaliation on a multilateral
basis
with our allies particularly our allies
in europe the byte administration has
said it wants to do things
multilaterally again
no more going it alone as the trump
administration wanted to
we we need to have those nations behind
us because they've also been attacked by
russia in various ways
uh and they've had outrages on their
territory as well
russia is a bit of an outlaw nation but
nothing has been done to treat it
that way beyond some economic sanctions
the time has come i think
for president biden to talk to the
french the germans the british
about doing something more systematic
with these two streams of threats of
foreign and domestic enemies
the russians and the hacks and what's
going on internally with the far
right and the violent far right uh is
the biden administration team
a good team for this are they in place
to do something do you think you know
them all well
well i do know them all well and uh
they're all very experienced these are
not
this is not anybody's first rodeo uh
in the biden administration uh they've
announced a good team
on national security and a good team on
cyber security
uh and they're off to the races they've
already started doing the kinds of
things
that we've been talking about here both
asking for review of what we do about
domestic terrorism
and also a review about what we do uh
with the russians and with cyber
security in general
the proof of course will be what they do
not not the fact that they're reviewing
things
but what comes out of those reviews and
what they implement
and is there any one thing you think
they should definitely not do one bad
step could be
lead to real disastrous consequences
well i'd be very careful about
retaliating on the russian uh
cyber network of its uh doing exactly
what they did to us
i'd be very careful about doing exactly
that back because people in class houses
shouldn't throw code we live in a very
glass house
we are very susceptible to russian
attacks as solar winds demonstrated
so before we get our own housed in order
before we
get our own defenses up uh we have to be
careful what we do in the way of cyber
attacks that doesn't mean don't do
anything
it just means be very careful and very
targeted about what you do
richard clark thank you so much for
joining us and thank you for your
insights
thank you brent thank you rhonda
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media
see if you agree with what the editors
of media had to say about the my pillow
guy
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime
trial network
back now with this week's winners and
losers in the media
as chosen by the editors of mediaite and
we're joined by aidan mclaughlin who's
the editor chief of mediate which like
the law and crime trial network
is part of the dan abrams media company
and aiden your first winner this week
margaret brennan of cbs for the
revealing interview
she conducted on face the nation with dr
deborah burks
at that point that the election was a
factor in communication about the virus
yes yes
did you ever withhold information
yourself no
some people felt you became an apologist
for president trump
tough questions aiden from uh margaret
right so that was already a very good
booking to get dr deborah burks who was
a sort of polarizing member of donald
trump's coronavirus task force on face
the nation
for this extensive and pretty revealing
sit-down interview
dr fauci has obviously been giving a lot
of interviews
about his time uh serving under trump um
this was
dr deborah burks's first sort of big
revelatory interview
uh and it was really well conducted by
margaret brennan who asked pretty
probing and tough questions as you saw
there
she revealed insights into what was
going on behind the scenes of the task
force
over the last year and one of the best
questions was
asking whether or not uh dr amber burks
had become an apologist for trump she
faced a lot of criticism
for the way that she spoke about trump
publicly um despite what he was
obviously doing behind the scenes
um so margaret brennan really pressed
her on that and uh it made for a really
great interview
absolutely and it's always a trade-off
between tough questions and then getting
the next booking if you're too tough a
lot of guests don't want to come on
that's right you don't want to sort of
batter them that
margaret brennan did a really good job
of asking revealing questions um while
still including tough questions that
sort of everyone expects her to ask of
someone like deborah burks who as i said
is sort of polarizing because of the
public comments that you made about
trump
uh it was a welcome interview and it was
obviously just a good get
to have deborah burks on for an
extensive sit down on the cbs news
sunday morning show
those sunday morning shows are very
powerful your loser this week
the pillow guy tell us about him
that's right mike lindell the ceo of my
pillow he's been having a pretty rough
few weeks um bad news sort of keeps
piling
one would not expect the ceo of my
pillow to be in the news so frequently
um it's not typically something that you
would expect of a ceo of a pillow
company but he's always been a pretty
staunch advocate
for president he's been benign for the
past four years
but then in recent uh
he's become one of the more radical
voices supporting the president in his
fight to overturn the
results of
that he culminated in him repeatedly
caught repeatedly calling for president
trump to invoke martial law
to stop joe biden from becoming
president and serve a second term
um that has resulted in financial
trouble for my pillow
a number of retailers like bed bath and
beyond and coles have dropped my pillow
now from their stores
they say it's not ideological they say
it's because uh the pillows just
the reason why those pillars are being
dropped in january has something to do
with
uh mike clinton then last night he was
just kicked off of twitter which is sort
of a final blow
i'll say it is well a real loser this
week mike lindell
aide mclaughlin thank you so much for
joining us as always with your insights
no problem thanks and thanks to all of
you for joining us and thanks to all of
you our loyal viewers for joining us as
well
thanks to the great team in law and
crime for getting us on the air and off
the air
during these continuing difficult times
have a good night
[Music]
foreign